hello and welcome to this video playing
a living legend and that a Cuba Puerto
Rico okay I'm sorry if I offended
someone so we have some pretty
conservative set up here by white which
doesn't mean it is bad it's just and the
solid side by the way I didn't upload
the game before that it was one of those
games we had this feeling and something
fishy what's going on from looking at
the profile and everything and always I
don't know what to do with those games
to be honest and as sometimes people
request that I that I upload the games
against she does i'm actually not
positive that he actually did sheet but
it was such a strange strange looking
profile again yeah i don't know i don't
know what to do that maybe i should just
stop looking at the profiles and just
play the game and simply yeah don't pay
much attention to two stuff maybe this
is the right approach I don't know okay
so what about this I would like to get a
knight to e form f5 and probably f5 is
not dangerous and you know I can just
take them okay so prevents that a direct
night f5 but I can still do it now yeah
I don't fear this much let's see
laughter f6 he definitely can force a
draw at least I don't think I want that
f5 is currently hanging and so he just
step out of this yeah okay yeah I will
kick him out with f6 and then I hope to
do something with the weekend square so
what's the deal carriage 8 f 6 is Queen
h4 again
I want to give them an easy draw in this
position I mean he asked this yes this
idea same but long-term my position is
really very okay because of the BG
foursquare maybe I have maybe I don't
get to use it the other living legend
whatever you can say about them is
playing very quickly okay stuff to get I
have six Xena ultimately with the Queen
rook night everything
what's the idea night discovery there
may be a night discovery rookie aid or
something no hmm right it's inconvenient
and he plays it like move move move it's
pretty I don't like why why is this
working because he's got this check out
which is Chang
Jeff yeah there are days where you sorry
shouldn't play chess and this is
probably one of them Jim okay black
resigns Joe did didn't I don't know what
what went wrong there yeah I mean blacks
idea is too plain idea 526 24 you stop
that I was simply taking taking on a
five and this should be actually very
okay for me I never get never got never
got f6 and this is really a problem and
if i get f 16 and this night has to go
back my position is totally fine but
maybe i don't get it then okay this
trade wasn't ideal but still shouldn't
be a huge problem maybe somewhere around
here I'm screwing it up he says I don't
think King age eight is good yeah oh
yeah it's not yet necessary and that's
certainly true i mean i can play
whatever quincy eight maybe quincy ADF
to have to cover this or whatever is not
right probably this
now that's it's okay no he's painting
stuff anyway great shrieking just seven
king of 2i Queen f2 I so don't believe
it's a huge problem and I simply don't
it's it's equal according to the comp
which I mean yeah I don't get a six inch
so I cannot play for any advantage here
I am he basically says that he believes
that he's better which is so good is not
true but it's easier to play for wide as
we have seen it could play all those
moves instantly maybe h5 I don't get at
six and it's just easier for wide know
this now i need to do weird things
assistant work he saw 96 quickly so i
have to play book f6 tanner yeah it's
uncomfortable it's just uncomfortable if
i don't if i cannot play a six this is
not good the thing is i don't believe in
moves like Bishop takes at five I mean
it don't it just shouldn't be an
advantage it just shouldn't be how do i
do that i mean okay i wanted to f6 i can
he can smash yeah i know that that
doesn't work so i just need to get this
in isn't that possible somehow if it
isn't possible to play a six then he's
better I mean that or at least it's much
easier for him to play it this maybe I
still don't see how i get f six then he
painted that
maybe maybe
yeah probably yes this is certainly an
issue that the bishops traded if i can
get the bishop to g7 i might get an f6
ultimate lame thing is once i get this
in the night retreats I play like goopy
4 and so on and then black is fine I
mean really fine but it's it seems that
it's difficult to get it in this is a
good idea though what he painted yeah if
I don't know white is probably doing
something like this and then this is
interesting the bishop will will cover
our coven I know that this doesn't look
good yeah but I can quite often activate
like this this is probably okay am I was
thinking I mean I'm a natural optimist
yeah but I was thinking that he i'm
playing for an advantage with that back
in f 6 in minute yes we saw it was very
difficult to do okay well thanks for
watching